Aquí tengo una pregunta del libro de Química y
Reactividad Química de Kotz, Treichel y Townsend,
y obtuve su permiso para hacer esto. Dice:
"Una solución de KMnO₄ tiene una absorbancia de
0.539 cuando se mide a 540 nm en una celda de un
centímetro. ¿Cuál es la concentración del KMnO₄?
Antes de determinar la absorbancia de la solución
desconocida se recopilaron los siguientes datos de
calibración para el espectrofotómetro". Así que la
forma en que abordaremos esto es que sabemos que
existe una relación lineal entre absorbancia
y concentración. Podríamos describirlo así:
la absorbancia va a ser igual a la pendiente
por nuestra concentración [A = mC], y podríamos
decir que sumamos la intersección en y. Si somos
puristas al respecto, entonces la intersección con
el eje y debe ser 0, porque a una concentración 0
debemos tener una absorbancia 0. Pero la forma en
la que los químicos normalmente lo hacen es
que ponen estos puntos en una computadora y
luego la computadora realiza una regresión lineal.
También puedes hacerlo a mano, pero esto está un
poco fuera del alcance de este video. Y lo hice,
fui a Desmos y escribí los números que nos dieron,
y esto es lo que obtuve, escribí estos
números, se ajustó a una línea de regresión
lineal y se obtuvieron estos parámetros: m
es igual a esto y b es igual a esto. Ahora,
podríamos pensar en cifras significativas. Parece
que aquí tenemos tres cifras significativas,
pero podríamos ver a la m y a la b como números
intermedios en nuestros cálculos. Lo que vamos
a hacer es usar m y b y luego la respuesta final
la vamos a redondear a tres cifras significativas,
de modo que esto nos dice que la absorbancia va
a ser igual a 5.65333 por nuestra concentración
menos 0.0086. Ahora nos han dado el valor de
A. Déjenme deshacerme de esto que tengo aquí.
Nos dijeron que nuestra absorbancia es 0.539,
entonces sabemos que 0.539 = 5.65333c - 0.0086.
Y luego, si queremos resolver para C, veamos:
podríamos sumar esto a ambos lados primero,
entonces tenemos que 0.539 + 0.0086 = 5.65333
c, y luego dividimos a ambos lados entre esto,
y obtenemos que C es igual a... Debemos tener
cuidado, en realidad todo esto es aproximado:
C será aproximadamente igual a 0.539 +
0.0086 / 5.65333. Y por supuesto queremos
redondear a tres cifras significativas,
muy bien: 0.539 + 0.0086 es igual a esto,
dividido entre 5.65333 es igual a esto. Así
que si queremos tres cifras significativas,
esto va a ser igual a 0.0969, de modo que la
concentración es aproximadamente 0.0969 molar.